From the first arrival of Europeans in 1492 to the Victorian era, the New World
The population of the indigenous people has dropped by 90%.
what is the reason?
Not conquerors -- they killed a lot of people, but the deaths and injuries caused by them are far less than
What they bring: smallpox, typhus, tuberculosis, flu, plague,
From pirates to cholera, mumps, measles, etc. on coastal tribes
Then these tiny invaders spread throughout the hemisphere, infecting people without resistance.
Tens of thousands of people have died.
These bacteria decided the outcome of these wars long before the battle began.
However, why are Europeans not getting sick?
If people in the New World are infected with diseases in the Old World, people from the Old World
Presumably, it will also infect the disease of the New World.
But at that time, there was no spread of the American plague to the east and spread to Europe.
Cut from 90 million to 9 million. If the American plague exists, it will seriously hinder Europeans.
The ability to expand to the other side of the Atlantic.
To answer this question, we must first distinguish between general diseases - like
The general cold -- and what we call the "plague" below.
1. The plague spreads quickly.
The speed of sneezing is higher than the handshake, and the handshake is higher than the intimate behavior.
The epidemic is more than this, and it is used more than this.
2. If it will kill you quickly, it will make you immune.
If you get a plague, you will die within seven to thirty days; if you are not dead, you will never again
Will not get the same disease. Your body learns to resist it. You may still carry it -- it
Live in your body, you will still spread it -- but it can't hurt you.
The answer on the surface is not that Europeans have a higher immunity.
Resist the plague of the New World - but the New World has no plague for them.
They have general illnesses, but no American plague can win the bid.
These are the deadliest killers in history, and they are all from the Old World.
But why?
Let's take a closer look at cholera: a plague, if drinking water and manure are not properly separated
It can spread in your civilization. London’s drinking water is incredibly poor.
Make it the world's cholera capital. Cholera can wreak havoc in densely populated communities.
Kill countless people and move on. But this is the key: it must move on.
In a small, isolated group, the plague like cholera can't survive -- it kills all that fits
People, leaving immunized people, then there is no place to go -- just like a big fire
Burn yourself to the end of the oil.
But a city -- a beautiful city on the hillside -- where the countrymen gather, hundreds of days a day
Where the baby was born: This is the sanctuary for the plague; fresh fire
Keep coming to the door. The plague broke out, then the latent disappeared, and then broke out again - never possible
Extinct.
Historically, the plague in the city has caused death faster than human reproduction. The city will grow up
Because more people are moving in than those who are dead inside. City growth
It was only after the 1900s that it was multiplied from its own population, relying on medicine finally from leeches and bloodletting.
Advancement to hygiene and soups has given people a means to reduce mortality.
But before that, the city inadvertently became an amusement park for the plague,
Immune people are separated from the public.
So the deeper answer is that there is no plague in the New World because of the New World.
It is not large and dense, and the sanitation environment is extremely poor. The cities that are closely connected to each other make the plague
survive.
OK, but the New World is not completely without a city, and the tribes are not completely out of touch.
Otherwise, the newly arrived smallpox in the 1400s will not spread.
The city is just part of the puzzle: they are needed for the plague, but the city does not produce
The bacteria that cause the plague -- these bacteria are the missing piece of the puzzle.
Most bacteria don't want to kill you, just like you don't want to burn your house;
The bacteria live in your body. Chronic diseases such as leprosy are bad because they
Be good at living in your body but not killing you.
The fatality rate of the plague is actually an accident, a misunderstanding, because the bacteria do not know
They are in the human body; they think they are here.
The plague comes from animals.
Whooping cough comes from pigs, and the flu is also. The flu is also from birds. Light is our cattle partner
Bring measles, tuberculosis and smallpox
For cows, these diseases don't matter -- just like a cold is like us. But when the cattle's bacteria ran to
In a person, something that makes a cow slightly sick can make you sick.
I am sick.
But bacteria are extremely rare from animal infections to humans. This is why humans of several generations can
Get along with the animals with peace of mind. To be the first person to be infected by animals is like
In the middle of a terrible lottery
But the colonial cities have increased their chances: there were animals everywhere; horses,
Livestock on the road, open slaughterhouses, unrefrigerated meat stalls,
A river filled with human and animal waste.
There is no better environment than this to spread the disease to different species.
So the deeper answer is that although the plague comes from animals, the chances are low enough that you must
Increase the likelihood by increasing the chance of infection, and the new plague needs a fertile environment
To grow. The Old World has a wealth of essential elements.
But why is the city like London full of cattle and sheep, and Tenochtitlan (the capital of the Aztec Empire of Mexico)?
This is the last element of the film.
Some animals can be used by humans - this is the meaning of domestication: animals that can be raised
Not just prey.
Forget the modern society first, imagine 10,000 years before the BC, when the human tribe arrived
all around the world. If you are one of the tribes, what are the local animals?
Can you catch and domesticate?
Maybe you are in North Dakota, intending to catch a buffalo: an elusive,
A violent tank with a long hoof, running faster than you, can jump over your head.
And in groups of thousands of strong.
By the way, you don’t have a horse to help you -- because there is no horse on this * continent*
The horse lives here - and won't come to you until you are finished.
Only you, some partners, and some stone tools. Native Americans are not tamed
Bison is not because they didn't figure out a way, but because the buffalo is a bison. No one is going to
- In the era of BC, the buffalo might be a very useful working animal.
But that is impossible - humans can barely domesticate with all modern tools
Bison.
There are no good animals in the New World that can be domesticated. Almost all big enough animals
If it is not too dangerous, it is too flexible.
But from fertile moon bay to Central Europe, there are cattle and sheep.
Goats: A small animal, in contrast to the human domestication.
If there are only stone tools, wild boars can compete with them, but they can be
Capture, raise, breed, and raise to eat -- because pigs don’t jump into the air, they won’t crush
All obstacles under the hoof.
The only animals that can be domesticated in the New World are: llamas. They are more than
Nothing is good -- this is perhaps why the largest cities in the Americas are in South America - but they
Far less than a cow. Have you tried to graze a group of alpacas in the mountains of Peru? It can be done,
But it is not a bad thing. These alpacas are some of the grasses.
These may seem to be featured examples. Animal species are not
How many thousands? That's right, but when you are still known to use fire, almost
All animals cannot be tamed. From the origin of mankind until the meeting of destiny,
Humans have domesticated about a dozen animals. And want to get
With such a high number, you have to include bees and silkworms; they are good,
But light can't build a civilization with honey.
These early tribes were not smart, and domesticated animals were not as powerful. The Old World has more useful
And easy to tame animals. With dogs, shepherds and cattle are easier, now people have partners to help
The machines that manage garment factories, produce milk and cheese burgers, and
Plowing the beast. This makes farming easier, and it means that settlement is more beneficial to people.
Causing more animals to be domesticated, producing more food, causing population growth and
Increase the density and see what happens. Small town village: Population: a lot; bring your animals; plague
Great welcome.
This is the complete answer: the lack of domesticated animals in the New World is not limited only.
Bacterial aboriginal sources also limit food production and thus inhibit population growth.
It has also restricted the emergence of cities, making the plague almost impossible in the New World. Complete in the old continent
in contrast. So one is full of plagues, one is not.
So when the fleet landed on the New World, no American plague could take home.
The civilized game has nothing to do with the player, but it depends entirely on
map. Access to large numbers of domesticated animals and their diversity are key resources
Can lead a complex society from scratch - and this complexity unexpectedly brings
A passive biochemical weapon is extremely deadly to the outside world.
If the game comes back, but if we exchange domesticated animals, history
The flow of disease and death will be reversed.
There is still a problem that remains unanswered. Why some animals can be domesticated, some
Can't? Why are American Indians unable to domesticate deer? Why can't zebras be domesticated? they
It is similar to a horse. What does it mean to "tamen" animals? To answer this question, please click here to see
part 2.